so what I want to do here is combine the
idea of fun facts from across the comic
book landscape with the process of
helping you understand various elements
of the coming book universe the way this
series will work is I'll present you
with a series of questions and for each
question you'll be given the option to
select whether it's true or false and
whichever option you suggest you'll be
taken to another video we will be
provided an explanation on why you were
correct or why you were incorrect having
said that let's jump into it true or
false
Deadpool was originally supposed to be a
villain true or false
Deadpool's healing factor is the reason
for his immortality true or false the
Deadpool comics were the first to
introduce recap pages providing readers
with a summary on what had happened in
the previous issue true or false
Deadpool was the first character to
break the fourth wall
true or false Deadpool has been a member
of the Avengers twice the powers of
negasonic teenage warhead in the
Deadpool film are the same powers of
which mutant and Marvel Comics gambit
who possesses the ability to charge
inanimate objects with kinetic energy
causing them to explode boom boom who
possesses the ability to create
explosive energy bombs of various sizes
and intensity which explode on impact
nitro who has the ability to cause
himself to explode or do you believe who
has the ability to create and release
colorful explosive energies which
detonate matter on a subatomic level
with that being said we're gonna bring
this video to an inn and I hope you guys
enjoyed this if you do post a comment
below let me know what you think and I
will catch you guys later peace